did you know that being a couch potato
could actually be part of your genetic
makeup yeah
it seems like everything is decided by
our genetic makeup these days
researchers at Aberdeen University
worked with colleagues and China and
they did a study with ASAP science and
they found out that that's pretty much
the case let's take a look
scientists studying mice have found an
interesting genetic connection after
separating mice into two groups those
that chose to run on their wheel more
often and those that decided not to run
as much the difference was clear in
their offspring after 10 generations the
running mice would run on their wheels
75% more often than the other group and
by 16 generations they were running 7
miles a day as opposed to the average 4
miles
it seemed their motivation for physical
activity was genetic all right is
everything genetic we like to think that
it's not we control our fate and our
destiny but at the end of the day is the
primordial ooze controlling everything
we're doing did you guys react to this
video the same way I did which was like
mice run 7 miles but I mean they can't
they got the tiny little legs I don't
know it's unbelievable I'm sorry what
was your question about the Blues what
would be the equivalent how many miles
for a human would be 7 miles per hour
yeah they don't have a lot else to do
yeah they're not working we're still
very babbling about God knows what
they're they're out there looking for
seeds so that's like as if it means
being a morning person and a night
person right so that that maybe that
like that's I'm a night person totally I
might kick something run run midnight I
get a little energy in me and creative
they say most the creativity happens at
night for I was just reading and I think
I'm gives you [ __ ] calm and but yeah I I
definitely think that it's in your
makeup you see fat families you know
yeah it's it's it's it is genetic I
think and um so how much do you guys
think we control how much do you think
is actually are you breathing you know
less than you think because I've read
all these books when about our
attraction to each other the explicit
sexual attraction and 99% of it is
unconscious you think you're making a
choice you think well I like this or not
you don't [ __ ] know what you like
because it's all happening unconsciously
like they realize that man that it's the
hip to waist ratio that makes a woman
attractive to a man or not not if she's
fat or skinny or whatever it's all these
weird things that go into it so that's
I'm saying more than you think you jerk
you're controlled genetically later that
video there's a great thing about um the
the couch potato gene literally that
you're that there is a gene that you're
less you're more likely to stay
sedentary not just that you the
generationally learn to work out but
there's something in you that makes you
want to stay and sit you have to
overcome that I mean I I literally feel
like I have it is very hard for me to
motivate in a way that I think is beyond
the normal human characteristic of one
is sit around like I am worked out in
four years and now I can [ __ ] blame
my parents this is fantastic
but like you have to have it and then
they throw this sort of the at the baby
throw this bony at the end like hey but
a lot of this is environmental and so
you have to overcome that yeah and but I
need a pill to overcome that right so
you couldn't do it that that's the part
that I find fascinating the the part
that you want to sit there and I'm with
you I could watch basketball all day on
a Sunday and not move but at the same
point I could go to the gym and run
around and be just as happy but you
don't have that I can overcome it and I
get none of that thing that we saw in
the first part I don't get this rush
from working out I don't I like I get a
rush from competition like trying to win
things or lose things but I like to be
involved in somewhere the scores kept
but I don't get like when I run I don't
come back and I'm not like oh man what a
rush what a lift I don't have that at
all you're not a competitive marathon
anymore of a competitive sleeper that's
right right right and you're like an
Olympic sleep you got a pillow top you
gotta just to jump into that you got to
have some disks Terra T are you able to
overcome your genetic predispositions I
really know I gotta say I got a call I
got a challenge the veracity of Ben's
statement that he hasn't worked out for
you to tell me that you haven't lifted
got something like this I believe so
really that's natural yeah you're not
juicing nope no not at all he's juicing
and not working out which is an odd
thing to do I've never you know I was
always an active guy worked
all the time so I don't anymore but that
says adieu with Mike I yet definitely
yeah I'm telling you you've more control
that's why you know they say the journey
of life is to becoming just aware
becoming awake because we walk through
life asleep that's right like over the
years like we learned that eggs are
shitty eggs are good they're right yeah
right turns out they're good uh it you
know four years in the seventies like
don't know don't eat you know too much
red meat and then now maybe which maybe
maybe it's okay certainly for certain
people and protein is definitely good
and so there's Bill certain drugs are
good for drugs are bad coffee turns out
good like you know a point great really
good for you you know so but one thing
that has never changed my doctor said
it's only if you put in this per sec
perspective he's like exercise they knew
it then they know it now it helps it add
years to your life
you know I have a daughter I want to
stay healthy and I have this sense that
even that is not gonna do it for me
that's that I think that there's a
predisposition I'm not a crazy person
but don't you have a sport you and Jordi
play bass I love playing basketball I
love playing softball I love playing
things that keep score it's just hard
you get old it's hard to find yes six
other guys to get together and give you
I was playing basketball so much that
TYT plays every Sunday I've played for a
year and a half on every Sunday never
been there I got injured like three
years ago and I haven't really returned
my injury I got an injury and took me
out so yeah hurt my back so I don't play
anymore but I'd like to I miss it I'm
better than you guys on that no get up
off your fat ass do some exercise you
could watch this while you're on the
treadmill that's where I do most of my
internetting